he seemed to be a bit of a sensation in
this contest how far can you go in
American politics
that's the White House
I just want to get into the governor's
office and bring some common sense
policies to the problems we've been
facing for a long time I got into
politics not because I want to be a
politician I'm a mama bear who's fed up
with what's happening and so we're going
to win I think we're going to win and
you can tell all of you can tell are you
aware that this election may not be
fairly accept yourself I worry because
my opponent is running the elections her
name's Katie Hobbs she's incompetent
it's not just me saying that the Arizona
Supreme Court called her incompetent and
we've already seen how she's botched
many elections and I worry I think she
should have recused herself we've been
asking her to recuse herself for over a
year now are you accusing her of fraud
though Miss Lake I'm in Q I'm accusing
her of being absolutely incompetent in a
worthless Secretary of State and I think
the people of Arizona are going to vote
her out of office and send her back to
the private sector and it's going to be
a great thing for Arizona